Một chân chân chân chân này, P thác xanh cho biết, nước này đã đầu khởi đồng chân xỉnh ngọt xáu phương ngâm,
tập chung vào Việt Nam chẳng các đường dây bốn bản mặt tuy, họ đậu mạnh tại Trung Mỹ, Nam Mỹ và Bông Caribeh.
Chân xỉnh đường dão chú bộ tương lạnh phương ngâm chín khai với sự tham xa của một lực lượng hôn hợp.
Được thành lập diên để phục vụ vụ nhận vụ này.
Chứ đó, nhai chân nhìn mạnh, Mỹ sẽ tìt trong sự dụng sức mạnh quân sử để chân nát họ đậu bốn mặt tuy tại khu vực.
Bốn được kóa là mũ đề sợi chực tiếp đến Anh Ninh Cú xa.
Lần năm các cũng cho biết, một nhóm tổ chến, giãn đầu với anh không mỗi anh,
giữa ở phó đã đuc điều đồng đến khu vực tắc chến, nhằm hỗ trợ kìm suán thất tuyên đuìen.
Theo chuyên thông Mỹ, lực lượng quân sự nãy trong những tháng tình đây đã pháng quỷ khoảng 2,000 tổ thuên,
đi cáo bộn đến quan tới buồn lộng mà tuy, và tiêu diệt gần tảm ưu tượng.